so quite a few of you guys and girls
have been asking me to cover some more
theme or obscure mythologies and that
did come across an Inuit tale that I
found both entertaining but also quite
horrendous at the same time
the story describes how a girl named
Sedna became the goddess of the sea all
of its creatures and the underworld
the story of Sedna's off the news by the
inuit as a creation story described now
certain animals came to exist and how
suddenly came to rule the ocean and the
underworld now I came across at least
five different variations of Sedna story
each one is joyous and confusing as the
last the first version describes Edna as
the giant daughter of an Guto the god of
creation and the highly respected datee
amongst the Inuit now for whatever
reason he decides not to feed his
daughter so she lashes out and attacks
him because she's hungry a sentiment
that I'm sure many of us can relate to
he then does what every good dad would
do when he's daughter tells him that
she's hungry he throws her into the
ocean but don't worry he does get a
chance to redeem himself and Sedna tries
to climb back into the boat you think
this is the part where he pulls said in
the back in the lesson is learnt and
they go and get some food right what if
you did you'd be wrong because this is a
pot where he si said to hang on to the
boat for dear life and then decides to
cut off her fingers even her to sink
into the sea and become the rule of the
underworld and the monsters of the deep
said in this big fat sausage fingers
will then form the first seals whales
and Morrises all three be and animals
that were hunted by the Inuit now if you
thought that stories a little bit weird
and quite messed up then there's plenty
more to come so don't worry in the
second version of the story Sedna is
upset by the quality of men provided by
her father so she then decides you know
what screw men I'm gonna marry my dog
we're gonna get a king-sized kennel and
wouldn't live happily ever after
and nothing's gonna go wrong needless to
say her father wasn't exactly thrilled
at the prospect of his new son-in-law
being a dog so he handled the situation
nearly where he knew I once again thrown
Sedna into the sea and cut off her
fingers when she attempted to climb back
into the kayak you may be sensing a
pattern here who said this father not
exactly being the greatest person but
there is a version was said there is an
orphan although this version isn't too
cheery either the people of the village
never Li like Sedna so in an attempt to
get rid of her they drowned her and
chopped off her fingertips but this time
my fingertips transformed into seals and
walruses that save Sedna and took her
into the sea I guess in this version
Sedna has somewhat of a happy ending
because she goes on to marry a fish and
lives happily ever after there is one
story was suddenly as a beautiful young
woman who rejects all the marriage
proposals from the hunters in her
village probably because everything
we've seen so far suggests that she's
to dogs and fish her father is an
approached by mysterious hunter who
offers him some fish in exchange for his
daughter her father force accepts his
proposal because why waste all that time
fishing when you can just trade your
child for some fish I'm sure most of you
have heard the same give a man a fish
and you feed him for a day teach a man
to fish and he'll probably just ignore
everything you've just taught him and
trade his daughter force of fish anyway
I think that's how it goes
so Sedna's father gives her a sleeping
potion and then traits her to the hunter
who takes her back to his nest on a
cliff the hunt of them reveals himself
as a giant bird spirit and Sedna wakes
up surrounded by a bunch of birds
wondering what life would be if she had
a caring father he does try to redeem
himself by rescuing Sedna but when he
sees the bird spirit creating an
enormous storm in its anger he abandons
all plans have been a hero and once
again for a Sedna overboard at least
this time he doesn't chop off her
fingers although her hands do freeze and
her fingers fall off anyway it doesn't
really seem I said there's ever gonna
catch a break in these stories but this
one does end of her growing a fishtail
making us somewhat of an Inuit little
mermaid just without any fingers or the
Disney movie most of these stories have
quite similar themes you have Sedna who
doesn't really do anything wrong you
have a douche of a father who most
stories throws her into the seeing cuts
off her fingers these things then go on
to form marine life and Sedna makes the
sea her new home she would often be seen
as quite a vengeful goddess and
considering the circumstances that led
to her becoming the goddess of the sea
you can definitely see why she may be a
tad angry it was a common belief that
hunters would have to pray to said
though because it said that she held all
of the animals of the sea in her hair
she would already release these animals
to be hunted when she was happy needless
to say that controlling the supply of
food men that Sedna was a well-respected
goddess that no one wanted to anger most
people throw offerings into the sea and
sing songs for Sedna there are even
tales of shaman's transforming
themselves into fish traveling into the
depths of the ocean and then combing and
braid in Sedna's hair
essentially playing the role of a parent
soothe an their child the story of said
knows quite a tragic one when you think
about it but she does end up living
among the creatures of the sea which she
appears to prefer the company of so I
guess it's not all bad there are a few
interpretations of said than that paint
her in a more positive way she's seen as
a reminder that despite your
circumstances the outcome can always be
positive sometimes you may have to delve
into the dark and cold places that you
fear the most in order to find the
riches that await I feel like this is an
ocean that not only refers to
tackling your fears but it's also quite
symbolic of the ocean if you have
previously heard tales of Sedna then let
me know which version you came across in
the comments below as always I've been
your host mythology and fiction
explained